hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
video that one of my subscribers
recommended to me it's called one way
street and animated story by
alexander grace before i start do not
forget to like
comment and subscribe and let me know
what video i should react to
next week let me
okay guys no rational person would deny
that being a woman in modern western
society
comes with a unique set of difficulties
ask the average man on the street what
kind of challenges come with being a
woman
and he will be able to list them off
with ease women are vulnerable to
physical violence
sexual assault objectification being
overlooked in the workplace
having to balance career and motherhood
and many other issues
men know of these challenges not because
men are especially empathetic and
sensitive to the problems of other
people
but rather because society has made a
concerted effort over many decades
to ensure men are made aware of the
difficulties associated with being a
woman
this is a positive step understanding
leads to compassion
and greater harmony between all human
beings however the question must be
asked
is this effort that men make to
empathize with women being reciprocated
or is it just a one-way street on a
societal level
are women actually interested in hearing
about the unique difficulties faced by
men
there is still a segment of the female
population that would deny that being a
man comes with any significant
challenges at all
they claim that our society is a
patriarchy and that every man is the
beneficiary
of male privilege after all men don't
have to deal with domestic violence or
rape in the way that women do
what do they have to complain about
just a sad comment when it comes to
domestic violence
i'm just saying guns are the great
equalizer
you don't have to be strong as strong as
men if you have a gun
while they might grant that there are
some worthy concerns surrounding issues
like child custody
false paternity and male suicide true
mostly these problems are brushed aside
as insignificant
in the face of what they claim are much
more important issues faced by women
come on i don't agree with that because
male custody not getting access to your
children that's that's a pretty big
problem
even though this radical feminist
perspective is continuously shrinking in
legitimacy
and relevancy even the average woman
still has difficulty understanding
the everyday challenges that men face it
might surprise women to discover that
far from feeling privileged many young
men feel disempowered
and alienated from the world around them
great progress has been made in
encouraging men to open up about mental
health issues
and feel more comfortable expressing
their emotions but as a society
we are still reluctant to acknowledge
the main reason why young men are
struggling
dating this will come as a surprise to
most women
they see no evidence in their own lives
that men are struggling with dating
to women it seems as though men have all
of the power
they think of the man who won't commit
the man who won't text her back
the man who doesn't even notice her
given the power that this man has
you have a hard time convincing her that
men have it tough
however this is exactly the problem all
of her attention is fixated on this top
tier man
who she desires but cannot make him
desire her back
no thought is given to the countless men
in the background who she doesn't desire
they are essentially invisible to her
and therefore
little to no thought is given to their
unique difficulties
yet these invisible men are not some
fringe minority group
they are in fact the majority
the word hypergamy refers to the female
instinct to mate with the highest
quality man that she can attract
from a biological level all women are
looking to pair off with the top men
of society a man who is tall successful
and good looking
will enjoy lots of female attention
because of hypergamy
who wouldn't want to be with him after
all he is a winner
unfortunately in order for some men to
be winners
there must be a lot of losers this
phenomenon is not completely unique to
men
everyone can recognize that some women
are more desirable than others
the major difference is one of scale
according to the dating site ok cupid 80
of men are rated by women to be below
average
i've heard that stat before
and that's actually crazy to me that's
so crazy
figures like this confirm what
evolutionary biologists have been saying
for years
that women only have eyes for the top
tier men
okay i will say that in my opinion
dating is easier
easier for men but not for the reasons
that you would think
dating is easier for men because men can
change things
outside of height if you're born short
that just blows
like that blows but if you're born
like i'd say like five eight and up
honestly like you can change
to become desirable like if you show
ambition
if you like you can
literally change everything other than
height that blows
where like as a woman like you can work
hard
and like you can work hard and like
build a business but men don't care
about that
and also like you have a time constraint
where men have like way more time
to like figure themselves out and
like they have stuff to look forward to
where as a woman like
it's it's more like times running out as
bad as that is to say
so if you're a successful man dating is
easy
but where does this leave the 80 of men
who can't get women to even look at them
too often it leaves them with depression
loneliness
and resentment from a purely biological
perspective
one of the best indicators of your
success as a biological organism
is your ability to attract a partner
mate with them and pass on your genes
is it surprising that men who struggle
to attract women into their lives
feel like they have failures too often
our society
demonizes male sexuality we celebrate
female sexuality as
empowering and beautiful an expression
of goddess energy
yet male sexuality is viewed as
perverted
violent and out of control i agree it
makes no sense like the [ __ ]
walk versus like what if a
man had like a man [ __ ] walk or a
player walk i don't know what the guy
equivalent but i don't think people
would go
male sexuality is just as valid as
female sexuality
all human beings want to feel connected
to one another and
sex is one of the primary ways that men
feel that connection
young men are not just sexually
unfulfilled but emotionally unfulfilled
they have a strong desire to be with the
women around them and yet
they feel invisible this feeling of
being completely ignored as a sexual
prospect by the opposite gender
is a uniquely male experience and one
that very few women will ever be able to
understand this unfulfilled need for
sexual
and emotional validation makes men
vulnerable to exploitation from
industries created
to separate such men from their money
there is a lot of talk about the
exploitation of sex workers
and undoubtedly there is some
justification for this but what about
the other side of the story
what about the exploitation of men who
fall victim to these industries
also the women more often than not i
would say
choose to involve themselves in sex work
webcam girls prostitutes strippers and
other sex workers
are well practiced in the art of giving
men the emotional and sexual intimacy
they crave
in exchange for money of course the
intimacy is an act
there is nothing authentic about these
interactions but many men are willing to
pay lots of money for the illusion
up until recently many men have felt so
ashamed of their failures
that they did not speak up about it they
kept their pain to themselves
at a massive personal cost even if a man
did want to open up about his
difficulties
he was not confident that the larger
society around him was interested in
listening
and they're really not especially if
you're a white guy like
especially when i was growing up that
was always in the media like the
privileged white male so if they had a
problem
i feel like they never felt like they
could like talk about it
because they're automatically
categorized in this box
the truth is that society has had a
vested interest in closing their ears to
the problems that men face
in order for things to keep functioning
society needed these men to continue to
participate
primarily for financial reasons the idea
of male privilege was an effective
pre-emptive strike against any
complaints from these men
that their reward was not commensurate
with their contribution
however the history of the west has
shown that as things improve
we make more room to hear the pain of
previously overlooked groups
whether it's ethnic minorities women or
homosexuals
hopefully now has come the time where we
as a society
are doing well enough that we have the
space and compassion to listen to men
describe the unique difficulties
associated with being a man
and for more content like this please
subscribe to the channel
and from what i've seen on youtube i'm
just like reacting to videos these last
couple weeks
i've seen a lot of content that's geared
towards men
and that talks about the difficulties
that men face so let me know in the
comments do you guys agree
do you disagree like do you think men
are marginalized today
and do you think that now they're
speaking up
and don't forget to like comment and
subscribe i will talk to you guys next
time